all right hello
uh
i'm ben dunning i don't work at yale uh
i'm a professor of
theology comparative literature and
women's studies at fordham university in
new york city uh
maury and hindi were kind enough to
include me in the smaller conference
that took place in 2012 and then
asked me to help with the organization
of this larger conference and uh for
this final panel
we are in many ways coming full circle
we are
uh
looking at
these questions as they bear upon
some incredibly current thought in
contemporary philosophy of religion and
critical theory
but also
with an eye to
ways in which this conversation looks
back to sources from antiquity
and most especially the apostle paul but
also
other resources in early christian
thought
our first paper uh will be from sarah
hammerschlag sarah is assistant
professor of religion and literature at
the university of chicago divinity
school she is the author of the figural
jew university of chicago press 2010
professor hamerslag is at work on
another book for university of chicago
press entitled sewers and sages the
renaissance of judaism in post-war paris
she's also concurrently finishing a
manuscript entitled broken tablets
levinos derida and the translation of
religion for columbia university press
her paper for today is entitled the
figure of the jew and the new
universalism
it doesn't look like a microphone i
guess it is okay
um well first of all i want to thank the
organizers of the conference um
particularly maurice for the invitation
um and also inessa for all her hard work
organizing everything
when maurice asked me to participate he
asked me to navigate
the intricate representations of the jew
in continental philosophy
and with an eye toward connecting what i
had to say back to the theme of the
resonance of
the figure of the jew in antiquity i've
decided to kind of reverse the paradigm
a little bit in my paper and rather than
thinking about the implications for
these
biblical tropes in continental
philosophy rather to think about
particularly the return of interest in
paul as itself a response to the trope
of the jew in continental philosophy but
this also led me to some kind of
uncomfortable conclusions on my part and
i'm going to try to explore this today
in which have to do with the
relationship between public
manifestations
and theory
so i'm going to essentially have three
stages to my paper the first is to work
out the relationship between public
manifestation and the trope of the jew
as i have developed it in my own work
and then to look at to develop the
relationship between the return to paul
in theory and it's
its ties to the post-modern trope of the
jew and then finally to
with some trepidation consider the
relationship between popular
manifestations of anti-semitism and this
return to paul
so like many of you i followed the news
cycle this summer with dread and
distress not only were the details and
images coming from gaza horrific but so
were there reverberations around the
world
of course the recent increase in
anti-semitic violence in france preceded
the most recent events in the middle
east but the war only accelerated and
intensified the frequency with which we
heard about demonstrations at and around
synagogues in france and the mass exit
of french jews to israel
it is thus with some trepidation that i
want to pursue today a topic and a set
of questions with which i am not fully
comfortable the connection between mass
demonstrations of anti-semitism in
france and the history of the trope of
the jew and french continental
philosophy
i certainly do not want to argue for any
strict relationship of cause and effect
but only to pursue a correlation that my
own work seems to make inevitable
in my recent work on the trope of the
jew and french continental thought i
used the events of may 1968 to
substantiate my claim that after world
war ii the jew came to represent in
france a figure for exile and
deracination the possibility of a
political position that resisted both
universalism and particularism but was
the product of both
when street demonstrations were at their
height that may and news circulated that
the student movement's leader daniel
cohen bendy had been prohibited re-entry
into france the crowd of protesters
erupted into the cry new son
we are all german jews this illustrated
i argued a fundamental shift in the
status of the trope of the jew in france
the jew had come to function as a symbol
for the margins what appeared was not
strictly on the model of solidarity but
rather such a cry also functioned to
make visible the distance and difference
between the students positions and their
claim
the students were not suggesting that
they were in the same positions as the
german jew but were rather
disidentifying with their own position
as french citizens and thus highlighting
a disjunction and an ideal one that
rejected the political battles of the
past by identifying with its negative
byproduct
this was a usage of the trope that i saw
corroborated in the treatment of the
figure of the jew by contemporary french
theorists in jean-francois leotard's
book heidegger and the jews for example
he differentiates the jews with
quotation marks and without
capitalization
from real jews in the final pages the
attack describes a lot of the jews our
only lot it is the only lot of this
non-people of survivors jews and
non-jews called here the jews i saw a
similar resonance in maurice paul's
shows on reading of may 68 as a kind of
messianic moment the negation of
patriotism quote the call to go out and
into the outside that is neither another
world nor what lies behind the world
and finally in jacques derrida's own
identification with the murano for whom
disavow was the only form of
instantiation and any claim of identity
was ultimately a betrayal the figure of
the jew was again mobilized to
articulate political identity as both
irrevocable and unrealizable
the possibility of this confluence in
both theory and in public manifestation
the possibility that the jew could
reflect a negation of both universalism
and particularism as they had been
traditionally cast in french politics
was itself the consequence of a history
of representation of the very
oscillation of the representations of
the jew in french politics between the
poles of universalism and particularism
in the 18th century the jew was
mobilized as a symbol of what
enlightenment and revolution
sought to root out or to rectify jews
were depicted as backwards tribal and
resistant to reason voltaire and his
philosophical dictionary described
beijuif as ever unfortunate ever
enslaved ever revolting
the instantiation of religiosity and all
that reasons sought to dispel in it
established a jew as the object of
regeneration toward the accomplishment
of france no longer mired in dialects
and regional identities and at the
napoleonic sanhedrin the council of
notables had to defend themselves
against the charge that they were indeed
a nation within the nation i'm
rehearsing things we all know
within the space of a century as jews
moved into the city entered higher
education and took to the study of
philosophy as if it were itself a new
religion their role in france's own
political negotiations between
right-wing royalism and universalist
revolutionary ideals shifted
jews switched sides and became the
object of anti-republican sentiment from
the right instead of voltaire's
adherence of tribalism they were dubbed
les de graciane by maurice barres in his
1902 tirade scenes and doctrines of
nationalism
blamed for the secular return of the
third republic they were seen by
royalists as the true beneficiaries of
the revolution in 1938 uber bogan
lamented the degeneration of the ecole
nomal superior the rise of socialism as
corridors and blamed its rabbis
brunchfig durkheim and only bear
this portrayal of course is meant not to
simplify the complexity of the figure of
the jew nor to treat its history as
monolithic but only to remind us that
the jew s figure has been mobilized
publicly throughout france's history to
dramatize its political battle even
barres seemed to recognize this when he
wrote in the figaro in 1890 the crowd
always needs all this is a quote the
crowd always needs a word of war to
rally itself it wants some cry of
passion that makes abstract ideals
tangible never has this truth been more
evident than at the present hour when
the disinherited are weary of programs
and even discussions sheriff is only an
adjective designating users monopolizers
stock brokers all those that abuse money
unfortunately barras's words ring true
once again today one francois hollande
is considered weak and effective sarkozy
hasn't caught up in a corruption scandal
and the national front has gained
significantly in popularity coming in
first recently in elections for the
european parliament parliament and
recent polls even suggest that the
presidential elections were held today
maria the pen would be the front runner
january 26 of this year saw the public
manifestation of anger towards its weak
government with le jour de coler when
thousands joined in a procession between
the plaster of bastille and laissez lead
to demand the resignation of hollande
and
call for the end of oligarchy the group
responsible for organizing this
demonstration and numerous which
followed resists aligning itself with
either the right or the left and makes
that principle primary instead it aims
at channeling anger from both sides by
merging a set of issues in its agenda as
their manifesto puts it we demand a
radical change and we are supporting the
coagulation of all forms of anger we
will take all of these deceptions is
still a quote we will take all of these
deceptions these fears and these
frustrations and manifest them as a day
of anger the group's charges include
failure of the government to listen to
its people bludgeoning of the taxpayers
starving the poor paralyzing the army
freeing the delinquents disorienting our
children perverting our school system
reducing our freedoms assassinating our
identity and destroying our families
while the organizers claim to resist
aligning with one side of the political
spectrum it's clear that most of the 30
000 of its followers on facebook come
from groups on the far right the
catholic right the royalists right and
groups organized around specific
right-wing causes the prince francais
which is against gay marriage and the
committee
organized against the islamization of
europe
there is among its followers in overt
nostalgia for marshall patent and his
slogan of work family and fatherland
fatherland excuse me one powerful
political force in all this has been the
comedian giudoney whose standup act has
been censored and restricted by the
government for its inclusion of a lament
over the lack of modern-day gas chambers
the playing of a soundtrack recalling
the sound of trains and his signature
canal an inversion of the illegal nazi
salute which has itself gone viral among
his followers at the george de coler
protest his supporters led a series of
anti-jewish chants jewish la france nepa
trois
or de france and israel assassin
given the very claims i made about may
68 is there a way thus i really i think
have to ask myself to think about this
jour de coler in conjunction with
popular trends
in french theory and is there a way to
think of it as itself a continuation of
the story i found myself telling in my
book
one thing is clear the jew has remained
an emblem to be mobilized toward the
incitement of political fervor and
clearly its meaning as emblem has again
shifted even as in certain ways it
remains the same
its consistencies as image of capital
and invisible power and on one level the
revival of botanist themes signal a mere
replay of one of france's darker moments
but the repetition is always more than a
return and the implementation of these
themes is itself a response to the role
that the holocaust has played in france
and to its effect in and on the jewish
community
in another recent project i've been
writing about the role of the showa and
french french in french jewish identity
formation as well as the community
shifting response to israel
there's no doubt that the 25 years or so
following the war witnessed a call to
conscience on the part of the jewish
community in france a reversal of the
majority position on zionism a surge in
jewish educational establishments a
rejection of the revolutionary bargain
which reduced judaism to a confession
and of course an influx of north african
jews along with its muslim neighbors
even as the trope of the jews circulated
among theorists in the 60s 70s and early
80s as a means to resist
communitarianism the jewish reality has
in fact headed in the opposite direction
immanuel levinos is a fascinating case
in point in this story for he is an
overshadowing figure for and influence
on the trope of the jew as it developed
in french theory and a dominant figure
in the resuscitation of the jewish
community and its integration of north
african jewish populations in the
decades following the war
in the history of the trope of the jew
he's one of the primary referents
they're not always named as such in
meditations on the jew and leotard
showing darida
in all three of them leotard for example
borrowed lavinos's formulations of the
jew as quote the forgotten of philosophy
paraphrasing lebanon's claim and beyond
the verse but judaism is a rupture of
the natural and historical which is
always forgotten even when leotard
references kant and heidegger and the
jews it is kant who was filtered through
is a contour is filtered through laminas
a kant now read as promoting a subject
built on heteronomy for blancho the
reference is often overt as he put it in
his 1968 dedication to leaving us in an
essay on holderland for the festival
jean-paul frey for quote for leaving us
in an invisible relationship with
judaism and substantial sections of
writing the disaster are in dialogue
with lebinos and then there's darada who
said in a due to emmanuel levinas but
levines calls us to think of a
revelation before sinai and rarely
address the topic of judaism that is
there that rarely address the topic of
judaism without at least obliquely
referencing levinos
at the same time lebanon was very much
at the center of the postwar jewish
renaissance that gave birth to the
colloquius intellectual sheriff de la
francaise
even today he's treated as the patron
saint along with rene kasan of the
alliance israeli universal which itself
profoundly changed its mission after the
war from spreading the values of france
to jews all over the mediterranean basin
to promoting the cultivation of jewish
education and renewal within france
lebanon himself wrote numerous essays in
the years following the war about the
necessity of the shift of the need for
jews
to turn inward toward their tradition
their languages and their sources he
counseled renewed emphasis on hebrew
but not in order to recover a dead past
but to teach the next generation to
speak from the tradition to the modern
world
he lamented the renewed exodus of jews
away from judaism quote attracted by
assimilation forgetting the vows of
fidelity which we survivors formulated
after the liberation
he spoke of the seductions of the modern
world and criticized those who failed to
learn the language of the jewish canon
he struggled himself with how to
integrate his vision of judaism as
detached from place with the reality of
zionism but came to embrace israel as
the site in which a prophetic politics
could be realized
for leaving us sometimes and certainly
for those who took up the trope of the
jew in response to his work the tension
between the trope and historical reality
between jewish ideals and a jewish
reality in israel could be harnessed
productively in writings that were
sometimes critical even if le'venos
bonsho and deridad took up that work
explicitly one function of the trope was
to insist that the distance
between the trope and jews themselves
not be collapsed
as such it functions as a kind of lever
against the self-righteous tendencies
within the notion of election and
exemplarity
and so far as the trope was itself
oriented around the rest nation it could
disrupt any claim of propriety whether
by jews or others claiming now to take
up their position as darydah himself put
in one of his later meditations on
jewish identity this is a quote a long
one a call of the name worthy of this
name must not make room for certitude on
the side of the destined wand whoever
thinks he has the certitude of having
been him him alone he first called as
the best of the class corrupts and
transforms the terrible and decisive
experience of the responsibility of
election into a dogmatic caricature with
the most fearsome consequences political
consequences in particular
this levignossa's work has had a kind of
afterlife that made productive use of
its tensions by figures who even when
they criticize him did so out of loyalty
to him and to his ideals
but there's another theoretical
afterlife to the post-war figure of the
jew which has used the tension between
the ideal and the real to denigrate jews
and judaism and to announce a new
chapter which seems predicated on
replaying the old theme such that new
political ideals in france are announced
over and against a maligned jewish
figure
given his prominence in post-war history
of judaism and france it's not
surprising thus that lebanon says
himself at the center of eternal theory
against the jew and against the
postmodern as though it were itself
somehow jewish
the most prominent culprit in the next
chapter of the story is alain badu who
has risen in prominence on the
international stage in the last 10 years
and even referred to himself in 2006 as
the most translated and widely read
living french thinker
baju often among
you among others including zizek and
jacques monsierre has fashioned himself
as the antidote to postmodern thought
and what he considers rather
inaccurately its ethics of recognition
instead that you consider himself a
champion of quote the same his target
against his identity politics which he
consistently argues is complicit with
capitalism imperialism and american
hegemony and he sees its philosophical
emblem in post-modern philosophy and its
championing of the jew lauinas is the
poster child in this move this is ironic
given that the relation to the other for
lebanon's precedes any sort of political
identity and in fact disrupts that kind
of adjudication tied to political claims
of recognition
furthermore in the reception of
lebanon's bible show leotard
each sought in his own way to use the
trope of the jew as a means of
transcending identity politics by
figuring the trope
the trope of the jew
as one that resists an ontological claim
to inhabit this ideal or instantiates
principles
nonetheless but you marched forward
presenting lebanos's attention to the
irreducible difference of the other as
that which must be overcome through
fidelity to the event even as bad you
admitted that living nasa's actual
conception of things was at odds with
the ethics of recognition associated
with identitarian politics he worked to
align the two at the same time they
emphasized the connection between
lebanon's ethics and a religiosity
that's explicitly jewish in character he
contended despite lebanon's
phenomenological derivation of his model
that there was jewish law that provided
the basis for lebanon's ethics and then
accused his philosophy of being nothing
but veiled piety
in the process leaving us with stages
the representation of the reconciling
jews to bed used pauline messianism
neither in his paul book nor
ethics did but do target did badu's
target seem to be actual communities of
jews or judaism but rather those who
speak in the name of specialized
identities on the right and the left
those communities demanding recognition
a list which i think he somehow thinks
is playfully conceived to include
everything from black homosexuals to
disabled serbs and prematurely aged
youth
thus the jew became for badu the figure
for identity politics even as the tropes
sought to move beyond it
at the same time badu was writing
political tracts that were explicit
tirades against actual jews in 2005 he
published a book in france entitled
in which he addressed the tension
between what he dubbed virtual
consisting in fact of real jewish
communities in the postwar context and
those he called authentic jews so the
real jews were virtual jews and the
authentic jews were not actually jews
the authentic jew he argued was the one
who says in the name of all others that
there is a quote that there is no law
separating them he is the one who took
it upon himself to break the divisive
law and devote him humanity to the
universal models for him began with paul
but also includes spinoza of marx and
freud
virtual jews in contrast he accused of
constituting jewish identity on what he
referred to as the sit complex standing
for showa israel and tradition and thus
cultivating a culture of victimhood to
shield zionism from political critique
that judas traded on the trope of the
jew but only in order to repeat a
history of supersessionism which
situated christianity as the new
israelite
in this version it was not a matter of
questioning the nature of election but
in claiming it firmly against another
more recently in 2013 he published with
erica hasan the essay anti-semitism part
two of
france in which he argued for the
legitimacy of contemporary anti-jewish
sentiment insofar as it was in fact
criticism of israel
rather than trying to disentangle the
two he argued the jewish establishment
had so tightly woven the two together
and so successfully silenced into
internal critique that anti-zionists
could not be faulted for treating
judaism and zionism as synonymous
the charge of anti-semitism he argued
was a cover for resisting any forces
that sought to question the legitimacy
of pro-israel pro-capitals and
pro-american forces in french politics
additionally that jew has been much more
explicit in recent years concerning both
how he conceives of politics and the
relation between that form and his
philosophy what emerges in all of these
texts from the saint paul book forward
is a new form of militancy one that is
all about responding to a call truth is
that product truth is its product rather
than a criteria by which one judges the
justice of one's claim for the point is
enacting change and the goal is to be a
subject of change quote merely believing
is not enough to inscribe the event
within the world for the only being of
the event is being declared
depending on his text baju calls his
militant fervor by different names
framing in religious terms in
relationship to paul paul's universalism
is not dialectical he writes in the
conclusion of saint paul it is quote a
measured advance across a distance
relative to perpetually subsisting
particularity
inevitably of course the symbol for this
particularity is judaism
those
those jewish conformers to the law
against which paul rallied
but jude has also framed his political
project as the next stage of marxism
calling it recently quote the communist
hypothesis but communism is itself
defined now in very vague terms it is
quote the demand for change for
egalitarian justice it is popular revolt
cleverly he defines it in the communist
hypothesis against patanism which is now
associated with those virtual jews who
use the charge of anti-semitism to
protect the status quo
the equivalent of botanism today he
wrote an attack on sarkozy is quote the
belief that the french need simply to
accept the laws of the u.s led world
model and all will be well
thus along with the trope of the jew
badu has inaugurated the trope of patent
and figured his virtual shoes on its
side so now jews are associated with
vichy
all of this allows him also to champion
the french revolution according to this
according to his communist hypothesis
the french revolution was the first wave
of communism and its model of
universalism distinctly milled him even
politics itself is defined only in terms
of militancy quote as collective action
organized by certain principles that
aims to unfold the consequences of a new
possibility which is currently repressed
by the dominant order
politics thus necessitates an attack
even on electoral democracy the
electoral process is forbade distinctly
non-political but rather another
strategy in maintaining the status quo
politics thus would only be some sort of
revolutionary action in all of his
redeployment of historical events his
symbols he also like the organizer of
organizers of le jour de coler and
here's my connection expressed the
desire to overcome the dichotomy of
right and left both stand accused at the
same time though bed unlinking himself
up to a marxian legacy aligns himself
with a leftist history against an
economic disparity and for egalitarian
justice
that said it's nonetheless hard to
ignore the consonants between vedio and
le jour de coler i don't want to
underplay their differences but only to
point out that this perhaps through the
very return of the jew on the scene at
the object of attack by the right and
the left that we can begin to see a
certain commonality at least in method
between the new wave of marxist
theorists and the right-wing movements
that coalesce around the jordan colere
baju has explicitly tried to keep his
distance from jones and his father is
calling that real anti-semitism as
opposed to his own polling politics but
with each side seems to have in common
is the need for a rallying cry against
which to overturn the status quo and for
each the jew becomes the symbol of what
it thinks against
when le jour de colera announced their
announces their goals and terms that
seem strongly reminiscent of fed to use
militancy
action overcoming the status quo
implicit here is also the
crystallization of anger then we can
once again declare a consonants between
french theory and political
manifestation coalescing around the
figure of the jew
one difference between bad you and
you don't a ironically is that one of
them acknowledges and owns the history
behind the symbols he mobilizes and the
other does not
the consonants that emerges when we
compare the claims of le jour de colera
with bad jews should remind us that even
as we are right to condemn those who
return to symbols of the past for the
express purpose of inciting anger we
should be wary as well of those who try
to claim one facet of a tradition
without attention to the complexities of
reception the residues of history and
the power of memory
one could say about the recent return to
paul in political theory what gershom
sholem so aptly said about hebrew in his
letter to franz rosensteig that one can
only walk so long above the silent abyss
from which no sound emerges for it is a
volcano
thank you
our next paper is from ward blanton
awarded reader in biblical cultures and
european thought in the department of
religious studies at the university of
kent he is the author of displacing
christian origins philosophy secularity
and the new testament university of
chicago press 2007 and also a
materialism for the masses saint paul
and the philosophy of undying life
columbia university press 2014
and with hint de vries he is the editor
of paul and the philosophers fordham
university press 2013 his paper is
entitled what is an apparatus
machineries of paulinism and the force
of the name jew
thank you and uh it's nice to be back at
yale
um i'm grateful to the organizers um but
i i won't go on i'll just jump right in
in terms of time
but i appreciate being here
so what is happening today to the
conceptual social and political
functioning of the name of paul
in relationship to the name jew in
recent philosophical readings of the
ancient apostle
a great deal i think in more than i can
say here but i want to point out some
characteristics we shouldn't miss
i also want to point to a few issues
which seem really pressing needs for
further research things without which i
feel there is no possibility for
effective refiguring of the function of
anti-semitism which is i think
constitutive of european discourses on
paul and philosophy or related european
identity and the question of christian
origins
so then two big questions by way of a
kind of retrospective of the past 30
years of european paulinism within
philosophy and i'll focus in this
discussion also on uh alain badu
also mentioning um
agamben
trying to keep you all from boredom by
saying things perhaps not often said
about these two much discussed figures
generally i want to discuss how paul
whom a european and christian repetition
compulsion takes
as a placeholder for the topic christian
origins
becomes also a philosophical placeholder
for the problem of contingency
technologies of the self and even a kind
of hopeless
imminence first then i landed you and
paul's rebirth as the subject of
contingency
as i try to argue more carefully in a
materialism for the masses paul and the
philosophy of undying life
i think that the philosophical turn to
paul is a very important means by which
political philosophy is attempting to
model cultural transformation for which
it's quite desperate
without the security of any assured
philosophical foundationalisms
which is also to say in lieu of any
compelling international political
agenda
in the absence of assured origins causes
or ends political philosophy has found
itself more ever ever more reliant on
the category of contingency as that
source of our being our political and
social potentials
and as strange as it may sound initially
i want to say that it's the centrality
of contingency within contemporary
philosophy which is governing the
forceful return of paul within
philosophers like alain baju slavoy
jizak and also simon critchley just to
name three
to frame the matter somewhat differently
consider that ours is a moment when the
most important strands of continental
philosophy are being miraculated in ways
that call with increasing persistence
for reconfiguration of the contemporary
study of religion philosophy and
technology alike
miraculation has occurred in recent
philosophy as if thought were being
drawn
at first imperceptibly and then with
increasing awareness and developing
velocity into vast and yet only hastily
mapped zones whose communicative systems
capacious but nevertheless finite
reaches characteristic tricks ticks and
traits
seem indistinguishable from an archive
of religious of the religious
particularly the imagined legacy of paul
given the inflation of what we might
designate this miraculating tone adopted
by recent philosophy
i
believe that miraculation serves now as
a much more illuminating signature
in
over the self-distinctions of many
contemporary philosophers otherwise uh
attempting to conjure and enforce in
relationship to each other other forms
of self-distinction
these self-distinctions uh just for a
start hope to separate philosophies of
the event
new materialisms
object-oriented ontologies and
speculative realisms just just to
tickle your fancy if you're interested
in any of those
you see the grandiosity of my initial
claim for your consideration over all
these different sects and schools which
define the buzz of the contemporary
within continental philosophy we could i
think more usefully hang the banner of
miraculation
what hunt devries has explored in
various contexts has a kind of repressed
philosophical and religious history of
the special effect
with that suggestion in mind
i'll say that in my cheekily entitled
book materialism for the masses which
i'll explain in a moment i began to put
together a recent genealogy of the turn
to paul and philosophy
but you can see why i think
much more of the same the turn to paul
is on the way
if the miraculation of philosophy is an
effective nomination by which to collect
all these new movements among the
continental philosophers again new
materialism philosophies of the event
object-oriented ontologies speculative
realisms
and if the pollination of philosophy
occurs against the backdrop of
miraculation
then potentially all of these movements
remain susceptible to this same
pollenization i feel that the question
of paul and philosophers is therefore
exceedingly important
indeed
important in ways yet to be recognized
even in the absolute explosion of new
work happening on paul and continental
philosophy for ongoing discussions of
the future of politics and jewish
identity
we must learn to deal effectively more
effectively than i feel we're capable of
dealing at the moment with the
repetition compulsions if i may say so
endemic to these discussions
and i feel our interdisciplinary
capacities to do so are still quite
limited
above all when we consider that the
miraculation of philosophy its
orientation around an elusive special
effect
is another name for repetition
compulsion itself
let's stick with the concrete now to
make a few things clear
in the in this book on pauline
materialisms i tie the turn to paul to
debates in france also
and to a lesser degree italy in the
1960s and 70s about the structure and
certainties of scientific knowledge
debates driven by in part by pressing
anxieties about whether marxist
critiques of culture could ground
themselves in scientific economic
categories
as if an answer the late 60s and 70s saw
a burst of new philosophical work
oriented around efforts to be faithful
to the idea that the academy
could provide life with neither fixed
origins nor final ends
this orientation yielded a minor
explosion of french french philosophies
of difference multiplicity
as well as philosophies of the event
also
described as philosophies of singularity
categories which incorporate uh just for
a start michel foucault jacques de rida
and azeal de luz
though i've also been writing uh
recently about
pierre paolo pasolini and uh italian
philosophy after gramsci in this regard
another another um
radically polanized area of contemporary
continental philosophy um elizabeth
castelli's
beautiful english translation of
passolini's script for an unmade film
about paul
quite wonderful is is published recently
um
in case you haven't seen it
in lieu of fixed ends or grounds
each of these philosophers tried to in
to try to turn thinking toward an
engagement with singularity or event
oriented ways of thinking
living as a chance happening a gamble on
a wing and a prayer so to speak rather
than something that could be guaranteed
by earlier epistemologies or some are
assumptions about the governance of
stable scientific or logical categories
it was to use the language of daradat
and de los the effort to break with
logocentrism a metaphysics of presence
or an ontology of identity which created
a need to articulate politically
forceful modes of post-foundational
political engagement
in this context the other influential
louis arthur
was central to my broader genealogy
um
and the rise of uh uh
neopolitism recently because alfizera's
own work suffered through we might say
this turned from ground to contingency
or perhaps even better the turn from
stable structure as ground
to contingency itself as our only ground
nice philosophical uh thought
echoing the other philosophers just
mentioned alphazire tried to unleash the
repressed contingency at the heart of
western philosophical speculation
all these philosophers claimed to be
thinking at a crucial turning point in
the history of philosophy
and al-fazir named this uh moment the
revelation of an underground current of
materialism within philosophy
we should note that materialism for
alphazer was precisely not a traditional
materialism
in the sense that thought and life could
be explained by being referred back to
some stable objective material
substratum
such would be after all the clunkiest of
traditional foundationalisms and even he
would argue a further repression of the
subversive or underground current of
materialism he wanted to unearth
instead he argued we must learn to
conceptualize a kind of founding or
original contingency a kind of accident
which itself cannot be controlled by
overarching categories of being identity
or causation
so
the stage was set and you can see where
this is going
who will be the appropriately motivating
exemplar of this effort to rewire
western political philosophy
in fact
only a few years later one of al pizar's
ever faithful students alain baju
would find in al fazer's favorite a
fateful move
uh um the real essence of a paulinism
that baju would also unceasingly praise
as harboring the political insight for
our time
transformative moments of political or
social life befall us
but also philosophical thinking from the
outside
our thinking and also our political
living come to grips awkwardly with what
alphazer called the encounter
uh with contingency
the transcendent uh a transcended object
or a sorry rather transcendent accident
quite different
becoming philosophy's new and most
illustrious muse
and because thought or political life
must speak in and through contingency
there is structurally in place a kind of
speaking which exists only as a kind of
uncertain risk
an act of faith
all our good news all our karook mata
being grounded only weekly hesitatingly
one sees very similar dynamics operating
in uh recent work um uh also referencing
alphazer in the plasticity of being in
the excellent writings of catherine
malibu or in the fascination uh with the
announcement and also lacanian suture
undergirding earlier uh uh discussions
by ernesto la clau and chantal mouth
about the notion of hegemony again i
think i think that the basic structures
here which are motivating to turn to
paul are quite expansive and so that we
shouldn't mistake the specific
references to paul for something which
is actually a much more global
transformation of contemporary
continental thought
as i try to show in my counter narrative
of paulinism as a repressed materialism
for the masses
obviously making a joke
taking a stab at nietzsche's reading of
19th century paulinism as a platonism
for the masses
it wasn't simply that with badu in the
late 70s and then later in the 90s that
al-fazirian materialism or contingency
fomented a fascination with paulinism
aljazeera's friend
a very interesting philosopher and also
a passionist priest named stanislas
stanislav
had already confessed in initially only
private letters that his own efforts to
create a kind of modern pauline
continental philosophy
were basically indistinguishable from
from what alfizer ended up calling a
repressed or underground current of
materialism
and while many continue to speak of a
recent return of paulinism within
philosophy we should also note that the
struggle for philosophical narrations of
68 is
was already deeply involved in different
factions competition to bring themselves
or present themselves as a more original
paul line or early christian movement
incidentally
it would be interesting to trace this
trend uh backwards uh into literature
concerning the french revolution uh as
sarah was suggesting as well uh
someone named jean-michel ray has argued
very admirably for example that there
was a sustained paulinism of
revolutionary discourse uh that we can
trace throughout the 19th century uh
with uh edgar quine jule michele
and victor hugo as as important
touchstones there
everywhere
people wanting revolutions to be pauline
and paul to be a revolutionary it's an
important backdrop
and of course the politically
significant question for all this whole
tradition is why there is this desire
even this repetition compulsion to
associate the two
and moreover why is it that paul returns
as a christian
rather than say as a jewish thinker of
the revolution which would be a category
that the french scene
over that entire period
needs i would say some education about
at any rate as for the scripturalization
or biblicization of 1968
you may recall that with their book the
angel
the self-proclaimed new philosophers
guillaude and christian jean-bay
presented their particular readings of
and of beneficial rather than just scary
dictatorial or terroristic revolutionary
transformations
as a self-presentation of themselves as
as a new christian movement often as a
new pauline movement
you may even recall that uh bernard
on relay v
immediately named the angel as the the
place for a new philosophy to start one
which would not remain beholden to the
old intellectual masters above all the
parisian masters
le khan
al-fazir and de los
a few years later in 1976 when baju
would pin his always very intensive
criticisms of the angel
he would defend his old masters at the
zaren lacan
by criticizing the angels overtly static
rendering of paulinism and christian
origins badu's words
but use is in fact an altarian and
lacanian critique
in desiring a merely static repetition
or a repetition of the so-called
original christian identity
lardro and john bay repressed the
singularity difference or unplaceable
and unnamable contingency
that participates in all vibrant
political movements
subsequently baju would soon begin to
press the combat further by pending also
a piece of political theater that would
press his simultaneously ancient and
contemporary political and pollinist
concerns further
a piece only recently translated and
published in english called the incident
at antioch
the incident is i think
an effort to win this cultural political
struggle philosophically by making
badou's own philosophy the authentic
repetition of a pauline moment a
repetition we might say in the spirit
rather than the letter of paul's
existence
if you haven't read this piece of
badou's polit theater and are at all
interested either in the philosophy or
politics of the recent turn to paul i
think this play is essential
in part because it clearly deconstructs
some of the flat-footed formalisms of
baadu's later booklink treatment of paul
the play first feminizes paul and then
loses her in a sophisticated
comparativism which ruptures all simple
identities
refusing ownership as it were of a
pauline legacy which itself remains
stranded between forties antioch or
corinth i mean here simply 40s
1940s europe on the other hand 1950s
china and emerging displacements of
anti-judaism onto an anti-islamism of
the
1980s uh perespanlia
which i think should remain
on our minds for all discussions of the
rise of recent anti-semitism among
french discussions
as an aside
one idea for future international
collaboration
stage a discussion of anti-semitism in
european universality by way of the play
itself
invite by jews
some others who'd be interested and then
refuse to allow the anachronistic play
of legacies and identities in this play
to be fixed into the very problematic
tale of european universalism that as i
will explain
i find to be endemic to baju and
zhijic's collapsing of a christian
origin story onto the formal categories
of universal versus particular
in a word
stage a discussion of paulinism whereby
paul remains jewish rather than becoming
the first christian
it would be an evolution in the
discussions
and it would uh and and it was this type
of paul i was trying to teach
philosophers how to read uh in my
rhetorical and political skewering of
early christian efforts to co-opt paul
as precisely a founder of christianity
rather than praising him as one of the
multitude of creative jewish partisans
so um
i just want to underwrite
also josh burns intervention which seems
quite significant to me
that said
i think we should acknowledge that there
is a great deal of work yet to be done
to clarify the respective biblicisms or
scripturalizations of french political
theory since 1968.
so much as being contested say in the
different paulinisms or different early
christianities being proposed by baju or
the new philosophers
for example we must not forget uh either
that baidu's paula
in the incident at antioch carry some of
badu's finest career-making attacks
against fukkodian historicism
reed in this play a politics which
remains stuck in the past stuck in
uncreative repetition
jules de los's stoic fascination with
the one all
as a philosophical category greed in
this play a category which as paula
describes at some length
becomes obsessed with the unspeakable or
mystical
and finally a critique of the
dissemination of philosophical
multiplicity which he identified
identifies with uh deredar
which in this play
becomes a kind of mournful uh politics
incapable of founding a new political
movement always always ever waiting for
something to happen
similarly we could also mention at this
time in france the contest between
claude lefors theologizing of the
political for example his permanency of
the theology theological political
um as being strictly opposed by
cornelius castoriadis counteraction of
the theologizing of politics by
references to early greek models
foucault's odd placement of the biblical
and later the christian in relation to
the greeks is similarly oriented around
these larger philosophical and political
struggles
in the late 70s
and early and 80s in other words there
was a great deal of struggle about where
to file we might say political and
biblical tropes in relation to each
other
and if i may say so a lot of work
remains to be done uh
even just on the french philosophical
scene in order to get even this level of
retrospective insight about the question
of anti-semitism in order to better
chart where it might be going
say in paris where a great deal is
happening now but also how this
trajectory differs say from what is
happening in rome
london or new york and um a
great deal
could be said i'd love to i think it'd
be a useful future project uh
collaboratively but it should go without
saying uh it's usually not that what is
happening now philosophically
politically and culturally culturally
with the gesture toward paul in france
britain or italy or the us are
absolutely not the same thing
at any rate
as i read it the turn to paul is very
simply a transparent crystallization of
a recent philosophical genealogy in
france just for a start which was
entirely absorbed by
and oriented around a kind of jewish
question which is indistinguishable from
the question of how one places christian
origins or the biblical in relation to
ongoing philosophical and political
desire
i want to say also that it is imperative
that the interdisciplinary ideas topics
or discursive regimes we are considering
hit on the effective modes of
reconfiguring these earlier forms of
debate
otherwise i fear the repetition
compulsions i've tried to analyze in a
materialism for the masses
will not only continue but in fact
dramatically expand as continental
philosophy continues to
miraculate itself
so a few uh concluding uh thoughts about
baju's paul
badu has at least two very different
polls his theatrical figure of paula
being in some ways much more comparative
textured and provocative
than the rather mathematized formalized
paul in his later saint paul
and while those who know me now i'm
reluctant to say it
i think it's clear that badou's
hyperlutheran reading of the paul in the
saint paul book has clearly had a
stupefying effect on his capacities to
stay and say important things as he is
constantly invited to do about the
question of contemporary jewish
identities which he often elides
unhelpfully into questions about
israeli-palestinian politics
already in the subtitle of badu's paul
book there is a fall into some of the
simplest traps of modern european and i
would echoing burns again
say early christian repetitions
compulsions around the name paul
the subtitle of the book after all is
saint paul foundation of universalism
ouch
as bad used pronouncements since the
publication of this book made clear the
force of this repetition compulsion is
all the more evident when the entire
point of his uh paulinism in that book
in his political theater and in his
constant self-referencing as a kind of
paul figure is that there are no
universals that there are no foundations
of any traditional sort but that all
such categories all such political
processes must be invented as if pulled
like a rabbit out of a hat from
nothingness itself
nevertheless with a subtitle like that
before the book is ever opened by jews
paulinism presents itself as yet another
purveyor of a flat-footed european mis
universalism which misrecognizes itself
as something generic or general even as
everyone else appears as problematically
particular
the situation only gets worse
when baju builds his poll from out of
the money and scholar gunther borenkom
and the equally but money in stanislaus
preton
so
invariably paul becomes a kind of last
jewish first christian figure
paulinism as neither jew nor greek and
in fact outdoing them both for
contemporary political relevance
greeks are stuck in cosmological holisms
totalities read logocentrisms
metaphysics of presence and identity
but even worse paul's jews are indices
of contemporary identity politics
by the same token i don't think i need
to add that rhetorically socially and
politically the name greek in this
allegedly pauline polemic does not at
all naturally attach to an empirical
audience of bad use
at all in the same way that the word
jews in fact does
it's badu's fault and he should have
known better
but that book contrary to many of his
own points
sets itself up for the worst kinds of
scriptedness in relationship to nasty
parisian debates about say french jewish
identity in relation to the state and
securitization of israel
as i read it
perhaps we could return to this but he
has spent most of his time explaining
how his post-al fazirian paulinism
that is to say he spent a lot of time
since the publication of that book i
think this is important to say
um he spent a lot of his time explaining
how his own post althesarian politism is
actually not
what his pollinism sometimes seems to be
namely a clunky foundationalism of the
universal which necessarily looks at
particular identity jewish identity
above all as an obstruction needing to
be sacrificed or disavowed for the sake
of the universal
in the saint paul book baju was just too
naive about the historical force of a
paradigmatic anti-semitism which rooted
itself in descriptions of paul in
relation to christian origins above all
i have an entire section about apparatus
and agamben
and it's even bleaker
but i i want to make sure that i don't
go over time so i'm going to leave it at
that for now thank you
j cameron carter is associate professor
of theology at duke university divinity
school he does research at the
intersection of religious and
theological studies critical theory and
black studies he's been a fellow at the
national humanities center and has been
the recipient of several research awards
his first book is race a theological
account oxford university press 2008 in
it he explored the connections between
modern racial theories generally and
anti-blackness particularly and
christian supersessionism
further still the book argues that the
emergence of black religious and
theological studies emerged precisely as
a research program intent on
understanding this problem
and
and construct lines of flights from the
eminence of the racial christian
imaginary itself
he is editor of and contributor to the
collection of essays titled religion and
the futures of blackness he's currently
finishing a book on the political
theology of sovereignty and black
critical thought or what he calls in the
book the theory and practice of in
sovereignty the working title of the
book which is contracted with yale
university press is the color of
sovereignty a fugitive history of
political theology
his talk today is entitled in
sovereignty in palestine negritude and
the reproductions of colonialism
good evening everyone
a quick word of gratitude to the
conveners of
this conference and organizers
thank you very much for inviting me here
and as well a word of gratitude for my
colleagues on this final panel of the
evening
i too want to jump right
in i fear that
i probably have too much here so at the
end i may start to just summarize things
and let's see how it goes
um
the title is in sovereignty
in palestine
negritude in the reproductions of
colonialism
or an argument in three stanzas and
without a conclusion
the first movement of
this presentation is called in sovereign
blackness
what does amy cesaire's concept of
negritude
neologism
that's roughly translated as blackness
have to do with the current
israeli-palestinian conflict
and not just the current conflict
but what does negritude have to do with
the now half-century
post-world war ii post-auschwitz long
conflict in this part or that part of
the world
and how by way of this conflict
illuminated
through or looked at through negritude
shed light on modernity
as a certain kind of spatial arrangement
how might it complexify our
understanding of racism generally
and anti-semitism more specifically
in this the time of a supposed
post-racial era
or what i've taken to calling an era of
the post-racial blues
the task i've set myself this afternoon
at this important
and it goes without saying given the
latest
offensive over the summer incursions
into gaza what not this timely
conference
of intellectual exchange
is to address or more humbly i can put
it this way make an approach towards
answering some of these questions
i must admit upfront that i do not come
at this topic as a clean slate
and if the truth be told you don't
either
i come at this topic in solidarity to
put my own cards on the table as it were
with palestinians
but that solidarity i want to make clear
is anchored in the fact that i'm against
anti-anti-semitism
and as one of the as one of the most
heinous expressions of racism that the
modern world has ever
produced
or put differently
because i'm against sovereignty
i'm also
here's something i'm trying to develop
in this talk i'm also against a
two-state solution
because i'm against anti-semitism i want
to argue towards
the structures of a one-state solution
and as i'm already on the record in
prior publications and saying as much
i'll just simply reiterate it here
as it's an important piece of the
argument that i'm hoping to unravel
in
elaborating this talk
namely that the modern world
is born of a fatal
christian mistake
whose roots go back to the beginnings of
modern capitalism
and the atlantic colonial slave system
that is it goes back to the era of
modern of the modern spatial nexus
between europe
the american hemisphere and the american
hemisphere and the african subcontinent
it was a form of christian
supersessionism
that is the backdrop against which
the modern colonial world as walter
mignolet has put it or the house that
race built
as when nemo lubiano puts it came into
being
in the transition from a period that has
come to be called
the middle ages
i only go with this periodization
because it's become convention though
it's problematic convention
to an era now demarcated as modernity
and parenthetically again i've taken to
calling our moment a medieval modernity
a strictly christian theological
supersessionism
the difference between jews muslims and
christians
being a theological difference
transubstantiated
into
blood difference
i'm thinking of the iberian olympians of
the sangre laws of blood which made
religious conversion subordinate
to genealogy to lineage to bios
that is strictly theological
supersessionism
transubstantiated into the beginnings of
a scientific biological supersessionism
and on the basis of
bios
or life itself
difference was established as a process
of what can now be called racism
with this
transubstantiation in place
the discursive terms were set
woven inside of a christian imaginary
wherein
an entire taxonomic logic of race
could emerge to establish
practices of difference that would fuel
that will fuel
a portuguese project of expropriation of
african peoples
in the mid 15th century from the african
subcontinent
to begin
the atlantic
chattel slave trade based on what we now
call race
such is the beginning of a practice of
racism
funded by an incipient
yet to be articulated
theory of race
it would take time before the word race
itself
and longer time still for the concept of
racism
as words to emerge in the modern lexicon
though clearly the theory and practice
of these terms precede their lexical
invention
moreover
these same discursive terms of race
slash ism
would be deployed by the spanish
to fund the processes of early modern
colonialism and settler colonization
and to extend the atlantic channel
slavery
operation begun by the portuguese now
into the antilles
they will be joined by other that is the
spanish and the portuguese will be
joined by other european nations
to extend both colonialism settler
colonialism and other forms of
dispossession across the atlantic
hemisphere
in all of this
slavery and colonialism settler
colonialism are themselves or prove to
be themselves practices of accumulation
and disaccumulation or aka dispossession
practices of value
and alienation
in short what i'm drawing attention to
is the link
between christian supersessionism in the
early modern moment
the forging of the modern world through
an imagination of
the human and the incipient
globalization of capital
a world or a house was built on top of
the earth
i'm describing the house that race built
this is a house a world in which contact
was refused
cultural intimacies rejected
in favor of what theorist naom chandler
whose annotations on w.e.b du bois
has forever changed both our engagements
with du bois and with questions of
racing globality what chandler has
called projects of purity
and ontologies of pure being
out of this
transubstantiated christian
supersessionism
which has within it the beginning
conditions of what we call now
anti-semitism as itself split between
anti-jewishness
and anti-muslim islamophobia
out of a transubstantiated christian
supersessionism
that has globally extended itself by the
vehicles of capital
and militarism and missionary conquest
the properly human
as it has been tied to
human property
was born
but let's linger in the cut
for a moment still on the issue of the
discursivity
of christian supersessionism in its
production of
anti-semitism if we can push that
language back to the 15th century to
fund a new antagonistic political
formation
the name of which
is a character the figure called the
human
in the constitution of the biopolitical
or what i've just been describing
the failed political did not cease doing
its work
or perhaps in continuity
pardon me in continuity with gil and
azshara's most recent work
theologically or religiously based blood
work
in the making of homogeneous
pure communities on the one hand and
biologically based blood work
in the making of homogeneous pure
communities on the other must be
understood as linked to each other
by this i mean that both theological
blood work
to secure the pure community and bios or
biology based blood work to secure the
community also secure the community
employ sacrifice or logics of death
logics of atonement so to speak
in the attempt to consolidate the pure
community that is the nation upon the
foundations of a singular and sacrosanct
identity a singular and sacrosanct
identity
hence there can be no biopolitics
without its corresponding necropolitics
the question is who gets aligned with
death
and who with life
in necro politics in the high middle
ages blood did fail political work in
consolidating the community and
determining who's in and who's outside
of the community
in this regard i'm thinking of the links
between soteriological and atonement
discourses in the high middle ages and
the the
concurrent cultural practices of
christian crusading
intent on securing a pure christendom
and now in the mar in the modern era in
the modern age of the biopolitical
blood still does fail political work
but in the mode of racial governance
and in the production of the racial
state that's invested in
purity or onto political oriental
political theology of pure being
racial governance names the procedures
of the constitution and regulation of
civil society and more broadly the shape
of the political and even the
international as such
the shape that is of sovereignty or
self-determination
aimed at purity
in the interval of a conversion from the
medieval to the modern that is in the
moment of the congealing of our medieval
modernity
the semite
as a newly invented race type
was born
or
to put matters differently still
anti-jewishness
or anti-judaism
or anti-judaica
i hope this constellation of terms
starts to get at what i'm communicating
to you what i'm getting at
metamorphosed into anti-semitism
the semitic what i'm trying to say is a
race category has a particular moment of
production i'm trying to target that
moment of production and pull certain
claims out of it
a new species the symmite is this new
species the new species was born the
semite
as a negative
biotheological figure
in relationship to another species that
was born in this moment
another bio-theological figure
namely the european
as white
herein is the birth of whiteness
even if in this moment
the lexical vocabulary was not in place
given this there's nothing natural
biological or otherwise about the semite
as such
or in its split racial identity about
the jew slash the muslim or the jew
slash the arab
gil anajar again i contend is right on
this point
but here's the next point
and i contend
the most important if we're to
understand the racial world the
production of the semite and what it
means to target the problem of
anti-semitism
as internally and ra as an internally
and racially split figure
the semite came into being
but only in relationship to another
normalizing figure
only in relationship to a figure of the
normal a regulative and regulating
figure
this is the figure of the sovereign
or he who carries out the work of
sovereignty which is to say the work of
rule and indeed of mastery self-mastery
whose pure being that is to say
universality coincides with such
concepts as democracy free markets and
freedom itself
in the work that i'm in the final stages
of finishing
i demarcate him this figure yes him
because the sovereign is patriarchal the
the sovereign is a kind of a
heterosexually normative patriarchal
figurine of the masculine
i demarcate him as a quote unquote god
man
indeed as an imperial
god man
whose soteriological work is to secure
life
by being the executioner of death or
that which signifies impure being
w.e.b du bois in the 20th century saw
this god man figure as he who anchors
what he called in the wake of world war
one and the rise of the treaty of
versailles the religion of whiteness on
the shores of our times
and yet
in so far as the modern world emerges
precisely as a process
of racialization intent on the total
regulation of life against any and all
forms of death i mean death threats
modernity's ideal
man capital m as a god-man figure
operates under the more secular or
humanistic name of the human
though the human and the ontology this
figure the human indexes as human being
emerges as always already over
represented and over determined by the
european slash western man
racially known
in terms of whiteness
that is as the white masculine as the
sovereign
what i'm trying to press is to is to
think the relationship between the
production of the white the production
and the birth of the semite and thereby
anti-semitism and that these two ought
not be collapsed into each other they're
produced right contrapuntally in
relationship to each other
the non-white emerges on the scene of
the modern in relationship to the
western european subject and if the
psalm if the saab alternate is to be
recognized as properly human
well gayatri spivak says if the sub
alternate is to as it were speak
she he must
must aspire toward and imitate this god
man aspire towards the normal imitate
democracy be for markets be for freedom
in acts of imitatio christie the
imitation of this figure of the human
she or he must aspire toward the normal
towards democracy freedom and the like
non-whiteness then is set up due to its
supposed deficiency
is set up due to its supposed deficiency
lacking autonomy lacking transparency
lacking universality mired in its own
particularity even its religious
particularity to aspire towards the
universal towards being like man
this will be
a vital
point as i move further in the
presentation in this argument but for
now
it's important that i make sure that i'm
clear about the process that i'm
describing here
i've been describing not a biological
process
race is not about biology though many of
us here i would presume most of us here
have already conceded to pushing away
from essentialisms
i'm describing the process of a
political formation
race racism is a political formation
i'm describing a process of political
formation the formation of
the formation that is the process of
europeanization
now
euro-americanization or we might just
simply say westernization
i'm describing race
ism as central to the apparatus of euro
americanization which is to say to
colonial sovereignty or to autonomy as
self-determining rule based on pure
being
the securing of purity and based on the
refusal of cultural intimacies and
contact
this means that neither the semite
nor the white comes first they are
contiguous neither the non-white nor the
white comes first they are contiguous
modernity emerges and modern racial
subjects emerge through a process of
digest
this term i take from france flannel
france fanon talks about this process in
black skin white masks in talking about
what he calls the lived experience of
the black
these are a set of experiences the
experiences of blackness that in
relationship to the political
coordinates of normativity are the
domain or the domain of what's real
can only appear the experience of the
black against this backdrop can only
appear as always already pathological
as madness
or in defiance of what's rational
it becomes a signifying trait rational
is a signifying trait of the universal
sovereign subject of western man
blackness appears as the antithesis of
this
as the disorder of positive value
and finally can only appear talking
about the lived experience of the black
can only appear as having as having
already been criminalized
and therefore as a troubling of
and the trouble with
the trembling within
the regimes of sovereignty a disturbance
of the nation state
if the poet nathaniel mackey
would speak of what i'm describing
drawing on phenol himself as the natal
occasion the natural occasion of
blackness i'm now pressing into
pressing it into the service of
understanding what happened to
jewishness jewish identity in its
supersessionistic production as semite
as the negative racial other at the
dawning of the modern age
as a kind of index of a death horizon in
relationship to the production of
whiteness and europeanness
what is the natality of blackness
i'm also asking inside of this what is
the natality of the semite what is the
natality of blackness
and what might it mean to think the
natality
the birthing of jewish identity next to
arab identity as jointly invented as
semite right next to blackness what does
it mean to think semitism next to
blackness and to read them next to each
other as jointly produced in
relationship to whiteness
and why not think these together
the jew the black
inasmuch as they are born
in relationship to a purported
transparent whiteness a transparency and
universality that whiteness
um
transparency and universality
um i was typing fast here that whiteness
from um what was i trying to say
a transparency in universality that
culminates in the figure of man the
human
fred molten puts words to the natal
occasion of blackness he tells us
he tells us blackness indexes
and irremediable homelessness common to
the colonized
the enslaved the enclosed
the despised
this is to say that what is claimed in
the name blackness is an undercommon
disorder
the disorder of the undercommons
that has always been there that is
retrospectively and retroactively
located
there that is embraced
by those by the ones who stay there
while living somewhere else
some folks relish being a problem
as amiri baraka
and nikhil paul singh almost say
blackness is itself a country and in
sovereign country
that's where i'm trying to get stay with
me
blackness is a country an in sovereign
country and
a sex that is not one
stolen life disorders the positive value
of sovereignty understood as a project
of race and nation a project of the
racial state
in the name of in sovereignty just as
surely as blackness is not equivalent
to social death or absolute dereliction
end quote
blackness therefore is underground
contact
the contact of the under commons
not just the contact of the commons or
the proletariat as marx might have it
i'm trying to remix mark's sample from
him if i may
this is the contact underneath the
commons the undercommons contact of
intimacy
blackness is what took place in the hall
of slave ships when people from across
the african continent were thrown
together
by europeans and had to invent meaning
invent language together
blackness therefore is life a mode of
life in the midst of an immolation that
sought to consume them but did not
consume them
it is a mode of life irreducible to
sovereignty
and the life death political ontology
and calculus it is shall we say
paraontological life
life that doesn't ground or secure
itself through the death of another life
that doesn't ground or secure itself
through the death of another
that doesn't have the fear of the other
as the horizon of its own being and
against which it must fight
blackness then is sociality without
exclusion it is sociality in excess of
the life death binary in which some are
aligned with life and others are aligned
with death as threats to the
nation-state
blackness is life beyond the mandate of
borders and boundaries and in this sense
blackness is paraontological to the
extent that it is in sovereign to the
extent that its socio-political
investments resist the mandate to be
sovereign blackness blackness refuses
the meaning of purity and stability that
colonial sovereignty assigns to it
i'm not making a totalizing claim about
black people how could i
i'm just one black man
that was supposed to be funny but okay
i know it's the end of the day but y'all
got to loosen up
i'm not making a totalizing claim about
black people how could i as if blackness
in black people are equivalent
no
blackness is fugitive from even black
people it indexes modes of life not
predicated on sovereignty and when black
people try to claim sovereignty it's a
problem
sovereignty has been invested in the
purity of the people
which is precisely what fugitive
blackness is not invested in
the question i pose therefore for us in
this specific context is this
can or ought or how might this be said
perhaps about
jewishness
to what extent is the palestinian
palestinian-israeli conflict or israel's
latest offensive into gaza
an exemplification by way of settler
colonialism of precisely the racial
sovereignty that i'm trying to trouble
hear and describe here and that i've
claimed here is part of a project of
purity i mean racial purity
of pure human being and thus a pure
political being
what does the statement the right to
exist as a jewish state mean given the
long dorray of colonial sovereignty that
i've just
sketched
i want to situate the
israeli-palestinian conflict within the
lines of this analysis the analysis i've
begun to set out here in that in that
appears more fully developed in the book
that i'm developing under the context
and the concept of the color of
sovereignty
and i want to imagine lines of flight to
speak in a perhaps delusion way
from the vantage point of a fugitive
history of political theology which is
the unthought history i want to claim
the unthought history of the palestinian
conflict
it is a reading
of that conflict that i want to suggest
that's in keeping
that is in keeping with the loaded and
weighty terms and words coming from
caiaphas's lips we heard of caiaphas
earlier today
at the approaching of the passover of
the jews as recorded in the fourth
evangel
and one of them caiaphas being high
priest that year said to them
i'm reading this as a statement of
political theology
said to them
you know nothing at all
nor do you consider that it is expedient
for us that one person should die for
the people and not that the whole nation
should perish
end quote
i'm interested then in atonement not
just as a theological category but as a
concept of cultural production
as a framework through which to
understand the production of negative
racial subjects such as the semites such
as the black as those who must die and
be dispossessed
in order for the life of another subject
the white the european
to posets to be self-determinative
thus i propose
a turn to blackness to the enslaved to
those shipped and cargoed made to be
cargo
as a fugitive vector from which to think
in sovereignty
or the problem of sovereignty in
palestine
and by think the problem of sovereignty
and the prospect of in sovereignty in
palestine
i do not mean to solve the problem
of sovereignty in palestine
i mean something along the lines of what
amy cezaire was getting at when in his
poem laguna calendar he says
i inhabit a sacred wound
paul's the wound is what i've been
trying to describe i inhabit a sacred
wound
a long silence is my dwelling place i
inhabit
a 300-year war
and if i may speak back to cesare and
extend his in-sovereign poetics
i would extend it this way can silence
speak
sovereign prose
interrupted
paratheological whispers
refused evaporating sounds of death in
palestine
immolated possibilities of an other
sociality
otherwise i'm interested in other
sociality otherwise
the cesarean task is to begin to
construct a contrapuntal
reading of the production indeed of the
conditions of the production of
present-day palestine of palestinian
resistance next to israeli claims of a
right to exist and the key phrase for me
in this as a jewish state
what has been banished to the zone of
silence but yet conditions the
palestinian-israeli conflict
and how does that which is silenced and
that um and that in that silence
animates the conflict how does it relate
to anti-semitism
how must our understanding of
anti-semitism then be altered
if we read it against the long history
of coloniality
as cesare has put it against the
backdrop of a very long war
the war that foucault i think was trying
to get at in his 75 76 lectures society
must be defended and he called race war
i proposed then a third social
coordinate of entry into the fraught
area of the palestinian-israeli con
conflict the silent spaces of negritude
or blackness the task is to inhabit this
impasse the impossible and deathly
passage of sovereignty under the
regulatory regime of the sovereign
okay
i have lost track of time what am i
looking like
okay
um
i'll summarize then the the next two
movements in a certain sense what i've
given you here is a real condensed um
expression of the total itinerary of the
argument
in the second movement that i have laid
out here i call um
um the effort towards a kind of
post-colonial jewishness and in this
section basically
i developed an argument about the way in
which i historicized the formation and
the development and the implantation of
european jews into palestine in the
middle east i pay particular attention
to the the place of um
the place of what happened post world
war one in the ways in which the british
um post world war one and during world
war one got involved in the middle east
and in palestine how they laid claim
established a british mandate over areas
and sections of palestine and eventually
in effect made palestine
an outpost of british colonial power
and then move to world war ii and
elaborate the ways in which led again by
the british
euro um europe
um carved out led by the british carved
out a space for a contemporary modern
nation state of israel in palestine as a
way in one sense to alleviate and
respond to the problem of hitler and the
way in which auschwitz worked but at the
same time to refuse to create a space a
mode a place of existence and
flourishing for um um european um jews
in europe itself in other words the
making of the modern nation state of
israel was a kind of convenient
production for europeans who refused
to make a space for jews in europe
itself so in a certain sense they
affected what i say somewhat playfully
but i do mean it intentionally they
affected the first two state solutions
so to speak
rather than
taking in and being
providing a space of intimacy and
cultural contact for jews in europe they
outposted it
into palestine
i playfully call this a kind of
two-state solution already as a part of
dealing with what happened in europe
culminating in auschwitz
from there i didn't elaborate the ways
in which
european jews go into palestine and the
ways in which they re repeat
practices of dispossession among the
indigenous people there palestinians who
by the way had cities and so on and so
forth and vibrant expressions of life
trade etc etc
the point of my analysis is not to say
who's right and who's wrong the point is
to take a kind of genealogical step back
and analyze the conditions of its own
production and link it back to european
conquest and colonialism itself and name
it and name the production of what's
going on in palestine as a kind of
reproduction of coloniality
that's the second movement the final
movement of the paper which i surely
wouldn't get a chance to get to is to
come back to amy cezaire and his notion
of negritude and read it as a political
concept
his effort to think blackness not as the
cultural property of black people and
therefore as a mode of pure racial being
owned by blacks but instead to think
blackness as always already open and in
contact with another
and to try from there to think new
political arrangements back in europe in
his case he was a politician in france
and tried to move the french towards
federalized modes of governance that
would have the once colonized equal
partners in the governmental structures
of france and thereby revolutionize
french existence and expand what
negritude itself is about
so what i'm trying to propose then is a
mode of identity that is trying to
escape the logics of pure being that
were put in place back in the dawning
moments of
colonial conquest
slavery and so on and so forth so i just
gave you a very quick reading of what
i'm trying to do in this project and
again i want to make it very clear this
argument is from the space of being
against anti-semitism but if we're
against anti-semitism as the kind of
enforced negative purity upon the semite
in the name of a whiteness the question
becomes
what shall jewishness become
just like black folk have had to ask
what shall blackness become if the
project of pure being has always been to
our detriment
thank you
go we'll go a few minutes over
and have a question
i'll uh take the prerogative and uh ask
the first
question here so first of all thank you
all and thank you to everyone uh
for a really very stimulating
day so um
this will
start as a question to sarah but uh
really then kind of
in a way it's also a question toward and
possibly also a question
to jay so i was very intrigued by the
project of trying to think through
the link between baju and the days of
rage the gerald de coler and
um
it strikes me that badu's
paulinism has him supposedly
opposing all particularisms which for
him i think in this context really means
nationalism
and so he's opposed to jewish
nationalism to zionism obviously but
he's also opposed to french nationalism
and i think you pointed to that in his
you know which he uh refers to all
french nationalism as vichy in a way so
it becomes you know nazified um and i
think he's also there for opposed to
republican universalism so to the other
instantiation of republican of
universalism in france right now which
is the republican form which i think he
also associates with french nationalism
so the participants in the days of rage
also oppose
those two nationalisms that strikes me
the the jewish one and the french one
but they're very explicitly not opposed
to arab or palestinian nationalism in
fact much of what they're doing it
strikes me is in the name of a kind of
arab or palestinian nationalism
at least for some of them
and i'm so i guess my question is for
and for
ward 2
how bad you deals with that uh
contradiction with
you know is he for him i think
the palestinians are this the oppressed
basically they're the underclass to you
know um they've taken the place of the
proletariat in in his you know uh
cosmology i think but how he
gets around the the problem of um
of uh advocating for essentially another
kind of nationalism
now he
uh
you know and this i think gets to jay
which is i think my problem with
a lot of people who support the one
state solution which in theory sounds
great you know it's anti-nationalist but
you know if you start to think about
any concrete real
manifestation of what it would look like
going forward it would be arab or
palestinian nationalist you know that's
what uh it seems like would be the the
result of it so it's hard for me to
to you know get towards uh you know
supporting that just in a real world
kind of sense but i'm wondering how if
you've seen where baju
takes on that question
i like your question
it's really helpful for me i guess i
would tend to think i would tend to i
would tend to rephrase what i find is
problematic about that you not in terms
of
supporting
um
nationalism but in terms of advocating a
kind of political action
which one would assume if it were
revolutionary would have to involve some
sort of concrete result and how would
that concrete result not replicate the
form that he's supposedly protesting and
that is particularly what i find so
problematic about
the
form of politics i'm sorry but is this
not on
i don't know how to turn it on it says
it's on
it says on but i don't know
um
yeah so i guess i would rephrase what
you're saying is
if you have a form of politics which has
to do with
enacting change and if
that is modeled on ideas of revolution
and militancy
what do you do when you have to actually
reinstate anything right and how does in
statement not follow so i guess all i
can really do is sort of replicate your
question back in a sort of more general
form i mean i guess what i would say
about juror declare is that
my sense of it is that
it's successful in so far as it were was
successful in so far as it managed to
conform a left and a right
anger um but that in fact many of the
sort of organizing factions are in fact
still on the right and and and not
actually
um
coming from um
islamic frustrations in france but
actually i mean what's been successful
is that somebody like jude jonier has
followers who are on both sides um and i
guess what was interesting to me is that
that that form
that the form of having to reject
partisanship
that that shared for bad you and for
this this new sort of form of
manifestation um and what i think is
troubling about that um is that it's
change but it doesn't seem to be there's
a sort of desire to eradicate
um
or to efface
the kinds of important historical
distinctions that shouldn't be
eradicated um and that that strikes me
as where you can see danger on both
sides and that's what i was really
trying to say so
i mean just to add
quickly um uh
you know i think it's a very interesting
question about badoo and their
contradictions as you say in in his work
um and there are they are contradictions
and i think you know i would want to add
that very strongly actually um there are
there are there are multiple badoos just
as there are multiple lavinosis
and uh and i'm not sure that in this
sense baju is is in the midst of a tiny
bit like more more problematic than some
of the things lebanon is up to as well
and and and and if one would have to to
work with baju and also against him then
then why would that be a big surprise
for any of us i mean caught as we all
are in in all kinds of contradictions
about place and and and generality and
so on um
i think i think for that reason that's
why i'm so interested in repetition
compulsion and this is why i think
freud's such a such a key figure for our
discussions you know because because in
some ways for me one of the most
essential questions for freud is is um
why is it that like despite the fact
that something's not necessary certain
repetitions in in in the cultural
formations uh they they come back as if
as if there's no way to get around i'm a
kind of destiny and that that's what
that's what i find most interesting and
i i think here i agree uh completely
with uh what what sarah has been saying
um
but but in baju there is a sense in
which his paul doesn't need to
underwrite any of the kind of you know
triumphalist european uh stuff um
and and yet it keeps coming back
um and why is that and and and i don't
think there's a good answer but that's
why i'm interested in sort of almost the
mystery of repetition compulsion and
not a great answer but uh it's there
i mean i guess that
i i'd want to ask maybe for further
clarification on why you why you suppose
um that a one state solution would
somewhat necessarily entail a kind of um
wooden effect which would be like a kind
of arab nationalism um but i mean
because the reason i ask that question
is because in a certain sense what i'm
trying to actually argue against now is
what i think is happening now mainly in
israeli nationalism and my critique of
nationalism is that every nationalism
needs his death-bound subject
and the palestinians are in effect being
perceived as constant threat to the
purity of the nation-state that that
gets encoded in his term
a right to exist as a jewish state so i
am calling for a one-state solution but
i'm not calling for one nation-state
solution i'm calling for something
a political formation that um exceeds um
the practices of of statehood and
statecraft as we've seen them
instantiating the modernity which have
been nation-state slash projects of
purity
yeah no i understand that and i i
totally get why
in theory and to theorists uh
you know nationalism is bad and we
shouldn't support it in any way and that
sovereignty is bad and these things but
it just strikes me that
except for theorists and their few you
know most of the people who um are on
the ground there don't really want that
and so in in like a real world situation
where there would be you know one state
uh
you know it wouldn't be this kind of
nice unsovereign thing i think it would
you know it would kind of lead to some
bad stuff going on and
you know in you know
i think most people would say it would
you know it would be you know a
majority palestinian state and that
would lead to some bad consequences for
jews and given that you know the kind of
history that has led up to the creation
of the jewish state i you know that's
why i can't go there basically
well um
i mean i could maybe just retort back
and say with some pretty bad stuff
happening right now
right and so i perhaps
i think the other thing if we we sort of
if i were to sort of give a longer kind
of account of the formation of the
racial world in relationship to
coloniality and so on and so forth one
of the principal things that it does is
it atrophies the imagination with
respect to the possible and and so
so
i am trying to argue that
there may be sort of to inflect maybe
you know leaving us in a certain way i'm
trying to sort of um inflect an
otherwise than being or maybe beyond um
levinas
aaron's block i'm trying to think the
utopic possible
um
and i think that what what i'm getting
after is
you know
it seems to me that there should be
nothing in practice let alone theory
that prevents
um the emergence of some sort of
political arrangement in which um um the
demands of a nation of purity
is that the kind of driving um
motivating force the kind of um
the
theological um the the political kind of
um uh technology that sort of guides the
production of the nation if we took that
off the table
i'm trying to imagine you know why can't
we imagine um
a kind of intimacy and contact
between um palestinians and um jews may
i ask just interject one more final
thing one of the reasons i tried to dial
this back and not go right to the
conflict and to go to its genealogical
conditions of production and link it to
coloniality because part of what i was
trying to say in setting up the kind of
colonial genealogical backdrop is that
the production of anti-semitism in
relationship to the production of
blackness in relationship to the
supremacy of whiteness is all predicated
on the refusal of contact the modern
world is produced in the refusal of
contact and so another name for
christian supersessionism
is the refusal of cultural intimacy the
refusal of touch and contact which is
why the slave ship becomes so
interesting to me because it's precisely
the place where people who are thrown
together without linguistic contact with
outright um all manner of other
cosmological um similarities are thrown
together and they touch they make
meaning and a mode of life happens sub
submarine like in the hull of the slave
ship what if that became a kind of
modality of thought for the political
the last thing because i can't help
myself because i totally get
uh
you know why in theory uh you know
that's desirable but i guess my sticking
point is why
israel is always the first country
that's being asked to give up its
national sovereignty you know given that
it's the one kind so one jewish country
you know there are lots of other lots of
islamic countries that want you know but
it's the one country that's always
supposed to be the first one to give up
its nationalism and that strikes me as
problematic
do you want to
how late do you want to go
please come to the
um
i only came midway through uh the
session so i'm sorry i didn't i really
wanted to hear sarah hammerschlag's
paper but i was
tied up in meetings so i'm sorry but my
name is ellie stern i i teach here i
have a question though for the last
paper two questions
um
the first is
the identification of colonialism with
christianity i i want to
perhaps provocatively push it a little
bit further most of the research that we
see now
on the origins of christianity
has has shown just how intimately tied
together it is with what we call judaism
its imperialist universal
ideals are things that really come out
of
a judeo a certain judeo ideal so would
we push this further and say that you're
not only ant
anti-anti-semitism but also anti-judaism
in other words we also say that you're
against
judaism to the extent that judaism is
also
implicated in
this colonialization project now pending
upon where you want to date the
beginning of that colonialization
project if you do it with christianity
certainly those ideas are jewish ones
certainly they are messianic so would we
also be
would you also be promoting anti-judaism
in your talk that's that's the the first
question
the second question here deals with a
little bit of the the the issue of
agency in the way you're describing
zionism
um
the description of zionism the
description of the jew that you have in
the modern period is one totally devoid
of all agency
where is the agency of the jew in
modernity here
and if you look at the history certainly
that argument that you're making
is an argument that herzl makes
certainly herzl does make a very similar
argument that this is europe's problem
but if you actually look at the history
of zionism and where it comes from as
herzl himself admits i never would have
said anything i said i never would have
had to even write this track
had i known what was going on in eastern
europe
the whole history of eastern european
jewelry doesn't even use a signifier if
we're talking the level of discourse of
anti-semitism it uses the signifier of
the jid
of the jew and of judaism
um that history
has to do with the way in which actually
out of marxism and the spreading of
marxist socialist ideals that jews
themselves came to the idea that they
were a distinct historical people now
jews who were east from eastern europe
were actually not able ever for 200
years were not able to travel to
palestine the borders were actually
sealed off for that they certainly
couldn't walk even into jerusalem it was
a lo ali alone on on on to on a a
standing institution jerusalem in which
ashkenazi jews were not even allowed to
enter to be able to
uh
say that yes this is a place that they
feel comfortable or that they would like
to reside in there were actually real uh
problems with immigration there so if
i'm looking at the history of zionism
i'm not even thinking about
anti-semitism i'm trying to understand
the agency of the jew in the modern
period and the idea that jews saw
themselves
as having acclaim to that land
historically and it was only because of
immigration laws
that they were unable to actually go
there so where's the agency of the jew
and your story
i don't think that i've first of all i'm
not trying to give a totalizing history
i'm giving a genealogy
and i'm giving a genealogy of a
particular kind of phenomenon so i'm
giving a genealogy too that's what i'm
saying i'm giving you genealogy also i
get all that all i'm trying to do on one
level is um i forgot you want to remind
me your first question but to stay with
the second one insofar as i understand
it um
the point of the second move is not to
strip anyone of agency it's to highlight
right in in
in making the the the kind of
highlighting of the the operations of a
kind of certain europeanization
right that would extend itself globally
that would make itself a will towards a
kind of planetary consciousness that
goes back as i said at least as far as
the 15th century i isolated that moment
because the will towards planetary
consciousness coincides with the
production of a racial imaginary we can
go back if we wanted to talk about other
things but the production of a racial
imaginary has a distinct moment of
origin so i'm trying to think that
moment and think about its ripples
throughout and ripples forward from
there
none of that is to say that
any particular jewish constituency
didn't have agency i'm trying to
highlight its relationship to a
particular agency um
of domination a particular agency of
europeanization and it's only in so far
as that i'm highlighting that
the second thing i'm doing is i want to
think the um
i don't think anything that i said in
the talk
mitigates against
jewish claims as you've summarized in
your the framing of your question coming
out of eastern europe jewish claims
towards a homeland in palestine none of
that is going on
that ain't even what i'm targeting what
i'm trying to get after is the ways in
which
moving into a certain place
almost necessitates
the dispossessing of others there rather
than thinking through what it what some
kind of cohabitation might mean we might
not like the fact but it is a fact there
were people there just like when um
columbus came to the antilles there were
people there those people were
dispossessed the possibility of contact
cultural intimacy a non-deaf life
relationship was not in the offing and
i'm trying to track the ways in which
that continues to shape this thing we
call modernity and how anti-semitism is
related to that we're quite a bit over
time so i'm going to need to jump in
here and i just want to know second i
just wanted to get a clear sense of the
first but would you also say though
that this is also
that that you're also speaking against
anti-judaism
in the sense that
the supersessionless certainly universal
um conquering and colonialist ambitions
of christianity are also very much
linked to isaiah and judaism to that
in the interest of time i'll make a very
brief answer and maybe we can talk
face-to-face afterwards my very brief
and direct answer is no nothing that i
said commit me to that in fact again to
stay very brief i'm invested in so far
as i want to think now strictly as a
christian theologian i'm invested in the
problem by which christian gentiles
came to think of themselves as
intelligible apart from their
relatedness to the jewish faith to
judaism and to the extent that christian
supersessionism is the breaking off from
the splintering of gentiles off from
the life the realities of judaism to
that extent i'm also therefore committed
constructively then towards
christians understanding themselves
necessarily as internal to the to the
reality of judaism so i hope anything
that i've said actually turns towards an
attempt to mend the breach initiated by
gentiles gentile christians that's by
which they slice themselves off
independently um and try to imagine
themselves as intelligible apart from
judaism
thank you very much let's uh thank all
three
of our speakers and actually
let's thank actually all of our speakers
here today and the audience for uh
sticking with a long and uh you know but
i think very very enriching day and i
invite everybody to join us for a
reception in the room straight back
there so thank you to everybody
you